les chér on va passer au buz du jour
pour ceux qui ne le savent pas depuis
mi-mars des centaines de migrants vont
évacuer sont évacués de la capitale pour
être transférés euh vers des des ses
d'accueil temporaire en région loin de
Paris le tout à quelques mois des Gio
objectif désengorger les structures
d'accueil des migrants en île-de-fance à
l'approche de la période olympique euh
voilà donc il faut pas qu'il y a de
migrant pendant la période olympique
apparemment ça gêne les les sauteurs à
la perche
euh un élu s'oppose à cela c'est Bernard
Carayon maire de laveur LAVOR LAVOR
euh il a lancé un appel au maire
afin qu'il refuse l'installation des
migrants venus de Paris et oui parce
qu'il veut pas accueillir les migrants
voilà est-ce qu'on est d'accord avec
Bernard ou pas petite vidéo et Bernard
ben il est avec nous et en plus il s'est
fait maquiller tout à l'heure petit
brushing et tout vous allez voir il est
beau gose au poil regardez ces
campements de migrants parisiens
vont-ils bientôt s'installer en milieu
rural c'est la crainte du maire de LAVOR
dans le Tarne Bernard Carayon qui lance
un appel au maire à résister un appel
soutenu par de nombreux maires comme à
Val du rink dans le Tarne c'est une
bonne initiative de Bernard Carayon je
trouve ces obligations d'autant plus
difficiles à accepter qu'elles sont
parfois imposé sans leur accord en 2023
Bernard Carayon avait déjà gagné une
bataille contre l'État il s'était opposé
à la création d'un centre d'accueil pour
les demandeurs d'asile merci Bernard
Caron d'être avec nous maire de laav le
maire
LR donc les républicains bien entendu
pourquoi vous refusez les les migrants
que les migrants soi répartis vous je
trouve que c'est déjà euh tout à fait
indigne et hypocrite de la part du
président de la
République de faire des migrants des
meubles qu'on déménage voilà et et dans
dans le but de rendre en quelque sorte
si j'ai bien compris la ville de Paris
plus propre plus attrayante plus humaine
pour les Jeux olympiques mais c'est une
hypocrisie folle parce que d'un côté le
gouvernement ouvre les frontières de
notre pays depuis depuis des années
500000 étrangers par an l'an dernier
142000 demandeurs du statut de réfugiés
dont on sait que 55 à 60 % seront
déboutés du droit d'asile et qui
partiront dans la nature et puis ensuite
ils viennent dans nos villes particulier
dans les grandes métropoles ils couchent
dans le 19e le 18e le 20e arrondissement
sous les pont du métro on lesè
sous détente dans le froid ou sous le
soleil et puis ensuite comme ça fait pas
joli pour le décor il faudrait les
balancer dans les territoires ruraux
mais je dire nous dans nos villes dans
nos petites ville du T du Cantal de l'Î
Villain des départements ruraux en
général on veut pas vivre la vie des
cités avant de de vouloir nous
transférer un problème que le
gouvernement ne parvient pas à résoudre
qu'il règle déjà le problème des cités
qu'il rétablisse l'ordre public la
sécurité et la tranquillité dans des
villes où les filles ne peuvent pas
sortir seules où elles peuvent pas aller
au café à la terrasse des cafés sans
leurs frères ou leur père ou la GABA et
de rigueur ou le contrôle surfciè et de
rigueur pour
sujet ou le contrôle sur ou le contrôle
ou le contrôle des trafiants de Dr
dans les C mais on veut pas vivre
ça
vraend ville de cité où on
doitter je par par exle des v
de si vous êtes allé par exemple à
sainti
récemment si vous voulez aller visiter
la la basilique droit de France c'est un
c'est un c'est un un bon moyen pour voir
l'évolution de de cette ville et de ce
département je suis désolé on n pas
envie de vivre ça mais il y a pas vous
confondez tout je c là vous vous
mélangez un peu les sujets pardonnez-moi
parce que là vous évoquez à la fois les
migrants puis vous évoquez les
populations qui sont issues de
l'immigration dans les cités et vous
faites un signe égal entre les deux tout
en tout en reliant tout cel en disant
que elles sont vecteur de d'insécurité
moi je crois que vous faites une sorte
de glououga pardonnez-moi j'étais
d'accord avec votre première partie de
discours lorsque vous expliquez
effectivement que ce ne sont pas des
biens meubles qu'on qu'on qu'on déplace
comme ça et que et dont on se débarrasse
votre seconde partie discours en
revanche m'interroge non ce que je
voulais vous dire ENF je n'ai jamais
voulu dire que tous les étrangers
étaient des délincants je dis simplement
que la majorité aujourd'hui des
délinquants sont des étrangers c'est ça
la
réalité même le
président
français il y a pas que des Français le
le 26 octobre 2022 c'est le président de
la République lui-même qui a dit 50 %
des actes de délinquence commis à Paris
sont commis par des étrangers et 66 %
des agressions sexuelles sont commis par
des étrangers c'est la réalité il faut
pas il faut pas conserver des tabous il
faut dire la vérité si on veut éviter la
haine si on veut éviter les
discrimination si on veut éviter le
racisme et et des réactions xénophobes
il faut dire la vérité et il faut
traiter les problèmes au fond et n pas
se cacher toujours derrière les les les
les mirages de la bienpensance tu
voulais dire moi je suis assez d'accord
avec Bernard Carayon je crois que vous
êtes maire d'une commune de 10000
habitants dans le Tarne laavor c'est une
commune qui est très particulière car
c'est une commune qui est très très
rurale mais qui qui se situe à côté de
grande ville je crois comme castre qui
sont des villes plutôt comme Toulouse ou
castre aujourd'hui la problématique elle
est démographique si on a un MIG qui
arrive de migrants TR migrants ça va il
n'y a pas de problématique or la
problématique on la voit il faut arrêter
de faire les hypocrites il suffit
d'aller à la porte de la Villette à la
Porte de la Chapelle là où des camps de
migrants s'aménagent aujourd'hui il y a
un lien avéré entre immigration et
délinquence et le second problème c'est
que dans ce pays on emmerde les maires
on laisse plus le pouvoir au maire de
pouvoir décider et de pouvoir être
maître ils ont une police municipale
mais on ne leur laisse plus exercer leur
rôle d'officier de police judiciaire sur
le territoire de leur commune on leur
impose des on leur impose des décisions
parisiennes qui sont prises sur le
boulevard Saint-Germain qui sont des ont
complètement déconnecté d'ailleurs c'est
intéressant ce qu' dit c'est très juste
effectivement je sais il a dit j'adore
ce mec j'adore ce mec c'est très juste
c'est vrai que la décision qui a été
prise par le Président et par le
gouvernement reflète une déconnexion
totale de la
réalité les il y a dans ma ville des
franco-marocains qu'on ne peut pas
distinguer oui qui sont qu'on peut pas
distingué des Français de souche par
leur comportement par leur style par
leurs idées ils boivent de c'est il BO
mais attendez on partage la bière à la
3ème mi-temps après le match de RBY mais
non
mais on partage pas de bière mais
on on y a des on y a des amis on y a des
amis formidables la question ne se pose
pas là le problème se pose lorsque l'on
transfère de manière arbitraire des
étrangers qui n'ont pas les codes
nationaux qui n'ont pas les codes
culturels qui n'ont pas les codes
vestimentaires dans des villes où on
veut conserver des habitude classique un
mode de vie classique voilà oui gu je
pense que vous vous sentez aussi méprisé
par les grandes villes et par le
gouvernement qui qui se qui prennent
leurs problèmes et qui se servent de
vous un peu comme une poubelle pour
mettre vos problèmes dans les campagnes
où il y a beaucoup moins de problèmes et
ils se servent de ça pour faire
effectivement un effet carte postale
avant les Jos et et et nettoyer Paris
juste pour faire un joli pour pour la
photo mais est-ce que vous vous sentez
méprisé vous en tant que que mer d'e
d'une petite ville j'emploerai pas le B
de poubelle parce que il serait pas
descent non mais c'est eux leur vision
c'est pas la mien mais ce sera pas
descens sur ce sujet vous savez c'est un
sujet où on est sur une ligne de
crête entre fermeté et charité c'est pas
simple c'est pas simple à
traiter chaque personne humaine a droit
au respect chaque personne humaine a
droit au respect et bien mais mais on ne
peut être charitable ou être humaniste
que si l' fait aussi appliquer les
règles de la République les lois de la
République le premier devoir d'un état
c'est de faire respecter ses frontières
c'est de faire respecter un droit qui a
été voté par les élus du peuple c'est ça
la la
République nous sommes héritier de
valeurs d'une histoire de paysage de
monuments et cetera qui font l'identité
de notre pays et et les Français vous
savez pas ceux du boulevard
Saint-Germain du 6e ou du 7e
arrondissement euh les Français ils ont
des des des valeurs simples ceux qui
sont les premières victimes de
l'immigration ce sont les ce sont les
classes populaires qui sont au contact
et en concurrence avec les populations
immigrées et encore une fois on on ne
crée que de la
haine c'est si on ne dit pas la vérité
si on si on ni la vérité si on ne fait
pas sauter les tabous Jean-Michel maire
oui bah moi je trouve c'est seulement
une question de bon sens je trouve je ne
comprends pas c'est encore une nouvelle
fois une démonstration de la d'une
politique française qui va dans le tour
dans le mauvais sens c'est que dans tous
les pays du monde quand il y a des
migrants des gens avec des populations
qui sont dans un état de pauvreté de
désespoir qui fait que ils se sentent
obligés ou ils sont poussés à commettre
des actes de délinquence par qu'ils ont
peut-être pas tellement d'autre choix
face à eux voilà on les concentre
quelque part oui enfin je parle pour eux
parle pas pour eux voilà ils sont on les
a pour l'instant les avait concentrés
dans certains endroits dans certains
endroits et là qu'est-ce qu'on se dit
bah tiens on va les prendre et on va les
disséminer en toute la France dans les
endroits il y avait pas de problème on
fait qu'en fait
mettre un coup de ventilateur dans sur
des populations qui malheureusement sont
oui non j'ai compris oui merci finissez
non non mais je vous laisse terminé sous
un tunnel ou quoi ben non non voilà je
vois pas l'intérêt de donner un Coupier
dans la fourmilire pour qu'il y ait des
des des problèmes partout